also als erstes ist so sagen es ist
wirklich ein sehr heimtückisches gift
denn es wirkt bereits beck minimalsten
konzentration man muss sich vorstellen
wie 100.000 grammbereich wie wirkt es
es wirkt dort wo unsere nerven
übertragung stattfindet unter anderem im
muskel das bedeutet üblicherweise
bekommt der muskel einen impuls durch
einen botenstoff und dann wird dieser
botenstoff in diesem nerven stark
abgebaut und das macht eine bestimmte
ein bestimmtes enzym wenn dieses enzym
blockiert wird so wird dieser sogenannte
neurotransmitter nicht mehr abgebaut und
sie müssen sich vorstellen dann hört
diese erregung in diesem nerven diese
signale übertragung nicht mehr auf das
ist wie ein roboter und wenn das jetzt
immer wieder fort steht dann bleibt es
im prinzip in einem tor erregungszustand
das bedeutet sechs team das diese
funktion nicht mehr ordentlich ausgeübt
werden kann und es letztlich zu einer
überregional sprechen folgen und das ist
vor allem was ist die art muskulatur ist
fatal denn es gibt keine kontrolle mehr
über die atmung und sie haben gehört er
ist bereits längere zeit im koma und
muss eben der atmet werden weil das
überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert sie
haben gerade ein sehr heimtückisches
gift genannt kann diese substanz
überhaupt bekämpft werden
es gibt hier verschiedene ansätze ja
aber es ist natürlich abhängig von dort
aus ist und auch wann diese therapie
angefangen hat zu greifen
also es sind viele überlegungen dass man
hier wirklich rechtzeitig eingreifen
muss das wissen wir aus anderen
vergiftungs da auch vergiftungsfällen
und jetzt wird sich zeigen inwiefern
diese therapie und sie haben es gerade
gehört er ist zwar ist
nicht mehr in lebensgefahr aber es wird
noch einige zeit dort ist dieser zustand
hergestellt wird wenn man sich ja
vorstellen dass dieses gift auch raus
aus diesen bestimmten strukturen
rausgeholt werden muss bzw
geboten werden muss und das ist
sicherlich kein leichtes unterfangen
kann wenn man jetzt eine sehr hohe dosis
hinter diesen anschlag vermutet jetzt
ist nicht wenns lebensgefahr wie hoch
ist die gefahr dass er trotzdem
bleibende schäden davontragen wird
ja das auch wiederum damals zumeist in
die glaskugel schauen aber nur eins es
ist auf jeden fall mal so dass das ganze
auch leider gottes effekte hat auf unser
gehirn wenn die atmung ausgesetzt hat
beziehungsweise wenn es längere zeit
auch keine sauerstoffversorgung gegeben
hat so muss man auch mit langzeitfolgen
dass im gehirn rechnen
es kann jetzt seien von leichten
gedächtnisstörungen aber auch bis sehr
schwierigen und problematischen
syndromen letztlich wissen wir auch ein
bisschen etwas zustand der gesamten
gruppe nämlich dazu gehören ja auch zum
beispiel einige pestizide dass wenn der
sohn eine vergiftung überlebt haben dass
sie zum beispiel auch an depressionen
gelitten haben unter ängsten und so fort
also man kann hier heute definitiv
wirklich keine fundierte aussage geben
außer das ist nicht unwahrscheinlich ist
dass ich da und dort diese
vergiftungsfall auch in seinem leben
abbilden wird